TAMPA BAY LIGHTNING AS
NORTH.
BRENDAN BURKE
HE SCORED!
A COUPLE OF BLOCKS PUTHEV
WENT RIGHT OFF THE STICK OF
RIELLY.
>>
TIED FOR SIXTH.
HE COMES ONE THE
THREE-ON-ONE.
>> Jennifer:E
EMOTIONAL.
>> Butch: YOU DON'T WANT TO GET
ON THE BAD SIDE OF THEMPA BAY, .
THEY ON THE BOARD, THEY WANT TO
APPLY K.
MORGAN RIELLY HAS BEEN ON THE
ICE FOLOT OF
SCORES!
DAVID .
HE IS INSIDE THE DOTS ALMOST. I
ONE.
ONON.
MUZZIN TO MARNERT HIS
PALAT.
FOR SERGACHEV.
THEY SCORE GO BYE WAY THROUG
NEW JERSEY NATIVE ROSSSS
>> Butch: WELL, COLTON HAS BEEN
ALL AROUNDE PAW, THE
LEFT P PR QUIT ON THE PLAY.
>> Brendan: RIELLY
OPPORTUNITIES. SCOREONAGH.
GET IT TO THE NET.
YOU NEVER KNOWWILL TAKE ITN.
PAUL.
OUT TO HAGEL.
THEN COLTON TO PAUL. HE
PLAYED.
AN UNBELIEVABLY GOOD PASS.
KUCHEROV MADndan: HAGEL.
TO THE GOAL LINE.
DRIVING TO THE NET.
THE PUCK TAKEN OFF T T
END IT!
ENGVALL WILL GIVE ITDIVE.
LOOK AT THE SCRUM.
E HITS IT.T UP.
HE FARED IT.